my entrepreneur friend Kevin David went
from working an accounting job that he
hated to in less than 18 months becoming
a millionaire using Facebook Ads Shopify
and Amazon FBA he now teaches people how
they can do the same in this video
Kevin's gonna teach us how to start
social media marketing as a beginner
step-by-step I hope you enjoy and
there's a special link below to get more
free training from Kevin all right
thanks so much for the intro Evan we're
just gonna jump right into this and I'm
gonna show you how you can create an S
Mme business and start earning thousands
and thousands of dollars per month
setting up very simple Facebook Ads they
take five minutes or less to set up and
the best part takes zero money to start
with this and you cannot start earning
money as soon as this week let's go
alright guys welcome to my computer so
what we're looking at right now is a
basic ad that you know myself and
thousands of my students use and run to
make thousands of dollars per month
basically what SM ma is and what we're
gonna be talking about today is social
media marketing agency and what that
means is you more or less get paid to
run social media advertisements and
digital marketing for these cash-rich
businesses right what we're gonna be
looking at today is a real estate
example but this works with the dentist
with doctors with insurance agents with
all types of businesses and most major
large cities have tens if not hundreds
of you know these types of businesses
insurance agents real estate agents
dentists doctors chiropractors right the
list goes on and so what you do as a
digital marketer right or as a Facebook
ad agency owner or a social media
marketing agency owner what you do is
you basically bridge the gap between
these olders you know these old-school
businesses that have you know a lot of
money but have no idea how to do digital
marketing oftentimes these businesses
are wasting money for radio ads for
billboards for newspaper ads for old
forms of advertisements that no longer
work the way they used to right
when these businesses should be spending
money with digital marketing done
correctly right with social media
vert Iseman and so what you do is you
act as the bridge between these cash
rich businesses they have no idea how to
run digital ads but have a lot of money
and need new customers new profitable
paying customers like every business
you're the bridge between them and
digital marketing right actually running
advertisements in this case we're gonna
be talking about on Facebook but you
know as you start to get better and
better at this you can start to run ads
on Google on YouTube on you know all
different forms of actual social media
so these are example right here of an ad
that's actually being run by a real
estate agent basically with the
intention of somebody being interested
in this house and actually clicking the
learn more button and you know viewing
the house potentially signing up to
actually see it and then you know
inevitably what we actually want from
running these types of ads is getting
people to purchase the property and so
you can see that this is a very basic ad
it's literally just a photo of the
actual house itself these are provided
by the real estate agent all you have to
do as an SM MA owner is set up a very
simple advertisement target you know
people who live in Las Vegas in the
general Las Vegas area specifically you
know in that zip code where the house
actually exists or just in Nevada as a
whole if people are trying to like move
to Las Vegas you know and things like
that but you basically just have to
target that specific area and there's a
few types of interests and demographics
that we've proven to work very very well
when it comes to actually getting people
interested in getting new leads and new
people interested in potentially
buying this home you know we target
people who moved recently right we
target people who have kids a certain
age because we've proven that they're
much more likely to actually buy a house
right there's also people who are
certain ages who are much more likely to
buy a house somebody who's 18 years old
right it's very unlikely that they're
gonna buy their first house versus
somebody who's you know 33 and so you
know as you get better at this and
specially if you learn from somebody who
has a lot of experience in this you can
kind of start off with a bang and you
know I have thousands of students in my
social media marketing agency course and
these people are charging you know real
estate agents every single day $1,000 a
month $2,000 a month to set
very basic ads this ad right here would
take five minutes or less to set up
total right and you only have to set up
a few of these ads and then just
maintain them right and so it's a very
very simple thing to do especially for
you know a thousand dollars of retainer
every single month so twelve thousand
dollars a year and sometimes you know
you can charge people two thousand
dollars a month
especially as you start to get more
experience you can charge people more
and more and more based on your actual
experience levels and so that is a very
basic example of the types of ads that
we get paid for every single day to set
up as the bridge between the business
owner and digital marketing because most
business owners know absolutely nothing
about Facebook ads so even though you
know it takes five minutes to set up
right they have no idea they want to
focus on their real estate business they
don't want to focus on running paid
traffic which is why they pay you to
actually do it so how do you actually
find these clients so we're gonna be
talking about a few simple ways that I
use to find these clients so I literally
just searched real estate Las Vegas
we're gonna skip all the ads even though
these are perfect examples of actual ads
that people are running to try to get
new potential leads we're gonna skip
like realtor Zillow Trulia red friend
these all these massive companies and
we're gonna open up some of the ones
that are just like you know everyday
mom-and-pop type shops so you can see
that there's one right here let's go to
the second page more ads we can see las
vegas real estate dot org Las Vegas
homes by Leslie and what we're gonna do
here is what we can see here is this is
a little extension called the Facebook
pixel helper so we can see that this
actual website does have a pixel so they
at least have a basic idea of how
Facebook Ads work we can see this
website also has a pixel so they have a
basic idea we can see that this website
also has a pixel so they have a basic
idea and so what we would do is we would
kind of run through and we would see if
any of these actual sites don't have a
Facebook pixel on them because if they
don't have a Facebook pixel on them then
we can you know pretty much know that
they really don't have any idea what's
going on and if they don't have any idea
what's going on what we can do is we can
sell them a potential service so you can
see that these guys do
and here we go so this site Las Vegas
Shorewood com they do not have a
Facebook pixel installed you can see
right here it says no pixels found and
so I would contact this particular
company and I would say hey you guys
know how much you're like how much
revenue and how many potential leads and
things you're missing out on by not
having a Facebook pixel because a
Facebook pixel is like the core
profitability asked one of the core
profitability aspects of Facebook Ads
it's what allows you to retarget
specific people so if somebody comes to
your website and you have a pixel
installed you can target that exact
person with Facebook Ads if you don't
have a pixel installed you can't right
so it's the it's one of the most
profitable possible ways to advertise
and we can see that that the this
business and also we can see that this
business as well does not have a pixel
insult these guys do so I would comp so
I would contact a claim and I'll contact
Sherwood and I would literally say hey
you know I run an SM MA I'd be happy to
show you you know just some simple
things that would allow you to
drastically increase you know your
overall profitability with your online
business excuse me with your real estate
business through digital marketing right
set up a call and then sell them a
service and it's that simple right and
we have all of the templates we have
everything that you need you know to
send the initial email to have your your
calls to do everything so that's just a
very simple way that I would do that and
that all started with just searching
real estate Las Vegas another very
simple way is to type in real estate Las
Vegas literally into the Facebook search
bar and then what we did was instead of
showing all here we actually showed just
pages that match real estate Las Vegas
and I would open up every single one of
these pages and I would send them all a
message saying hey you know my name is
Kevin
I run a social media marketing company
IB I'd love to show you you know what we
can do and then I might outline like a
few things based on their website that
could increase conversions you know like
maybe they don't have a button or it's
not optimized for mobile or they don't
have a pixel or they don't have enough
you know images done in the correct way
or they're not running any ads
themselves right we can see that these
guys actually are and so I would message
every single one of these companies and
I would send them all some type of
template
saying that you know I've run a digital
marketing company I'd be more than happy
to you know give you a free evaluation
of your social media presence and see
how I could help you actually run you
know digital advertisements and offering
to do that for free gets your foot in
the door and really like allows you to
kind of create a relationship and start
building rapport when otherwise it's
very difficult to actually kind of get
your foot in the door so doing it for
free is definitely a way that I would
100% recommend to get started in that
aspect and then the third way is BNI and
what BNI actually is is a business
networking corporation right where small
business owners go to meet other small
business owners learn about you know
specific things that those small
business owners are doing and things
like that and so BNI you can actually
search for all around the United States
and we saw that I just searched BNI Las
Vegas here we can see that they do have
a chapter there and so what you can do
is you can sign up and I think the first
few times that you go to these events
it's free and you can just go out
network with people if you're a people
person like some people are then this is
the perfect way to go meet people say
that you do digital marketing and you'd
be happy to you know set up a free
appointment where you could do an
evaluation for them that's an amazing
way that my students thousands of my
students get clients every single day to
pay them $1,000 a month $2,000 a month
or even more and the best part is it
takes no money to actually get started
doing this so it's a very very good way
that you can create a very profitable
large scale business with no money to
get started all right guys I hope you
enjoyed that quick look into how to
start your own profitable SMM a business
Evan thanks again for having me and guys
stay tuned because Evan has one more
thing to tell you real quick kevin is
having a free webinar training to take
you deeper and show you step-by-step how
you can make more money if you're
interested in checking it out the link
is in the description below if you want
Kevin's advice on how to become a
millionaire check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and I want to prove to you that
you don't have to be a world-class a
leading expert to actually get started
so we're going to talk about how to
choose your digital course topic and how
to get started
you